if you notice we're all wearing red
today because it's Go Red For Women day
part of a month-long national campaign
to raise awareness for women's heart
health heart disease is the leading
cause of death for American women it
kills about 300,000 each year but a new
survey finds that less than half of
women are aware of the danger about 60%
of women don't know critical components
of their cardiac health like their
cholesterol numbers blood sugar levels
or body mass index our doctor Taryn Rula
is a cardiologist at northwell health
good morning good morning
heart disease still the leading cause of
death for men and women in America why
are women at such a high risk I think
there's two things going on the first is
as a medical community we have
understudied women we have under
diagnosed them and we have under treated
them they don't get the same medical or
procedural treatments that men receive
in addition there's obviously an
awareness problem and the Go Red For
Women campaign was started in 2004 has
done a lot but we're still not where we
need to be women do not recognize that
this is their biggest threat they don't
recognize the risk factors and how to
manage them they don't recognize
symptoms and I think one of the main
problems and we were discussing this is
it's not personal enough to women one of
the best things that go Red For Women
campaign has done is put faces to this
disease if you go to the website it says
real women real stories and I think when
you see the face of a 40 year old woman
who says I was fit and exercising and I
had a heart attack or a 35 year old
woman who had a stroke suddenly it
becomes personal and not just a
statistic that one woman dies every
minute it means more yeah I feel it's
very personal we ask people to go on
Facebook and Twitter you know both my
parents died of heart attack and heart
attacks and I sit here today at the age
of 63 I've outlived them both so I take
it very very seriously but on Facebook
Marie I relate to you she said I just
turned 40 I have a strong history of
heart disease on my mother's side of the
family what should I be doing now and
what should I be discussing because is
it genetic I always think that it is it
can be and it's great that she knows she
has a family history that's one thing we
tell people is ask your family members
when did they get diagnosed what did
they die from you need to have that
information and bring it to your doctor
well once you know that in a way it's
almost like the deck is stacked a little
against you so you have to be even more
aggressive about managing your risk
factors so what you need to do is talk
to your doctor about your numbers you
need to know
your blood pressure your cholesterol
your body mass index your fasting blood
sugar need to be armed with that
information and then have your doctor
tell you what your risk is of
cardiovascular disease and work with you
on managing your risk factors what are
some of the risk factors so main risk
factors that we always talk about
hypertension hypercholesterolemia
smoking being overweight but then women
don't think about things like migraine
polycystic ovarian syndrome lupus or
rheumatoid arthritis early menopause
some of these can be risk factors too
dr. taryn are all really good
information thank you so much and Tara
will answer your questions about heart
health in a live facebook chat this
morning so you can take part by visiting
our CBS this morning Facebook page
it's expected to start around 10:15 and
yes you can get some free medical advice
that looks like that